année après année le succès de
l'enseignement privé se confirme
la proportion d'élèves de maternelle et
de primaire scolarisées dans
l'enseignement privé sous et hors
contrat a encore augmenté cette année et
est passé à 13 7%
quelles sont les raisons de ce choix
c'était plus ce départ
un choix de proximité par rapport à
notre domicile et aussi la réputation de
l'école qui avait une image plutôt des
cols familiale
de petites structures de petits
effectifs donc c'est ce qui nous avait
attiré en fait au départ ce succès n'a
plus grand chose à voir avec
l'instruction religieuse c'est la
qualité de l'encadrement qui est
plébiscité les familles sont attirés par
le fait que l'enseignement privé
s'efforce de construire un parcours
scolaire individualisé pour chaque élève
je suis élitisme mais pour chaque enfant
suivant ses propres capacités notre but
c'est de tirer chaque enfant vers son
maximum et pas de les faire tous
atteindre le même maximum les
établissements hors contrat scolarise
moins de 1% des enfants mais leur nombre
va croissant
c'est souvent la promesse d'une autre
pédagogie qui attire les parents comme
c'est le cas par exemple pour les écoles
montessori au fait qu'il fallait
clarifier les choses qu'on attendait
mondiale est valentin de voitures vélos
la philosophie montessori c'est que
chacun doit apprendre à ses vêtements
les enfants évoluent dans une classe où
il ya le mélange des âges entre 3 et 6
ans on tient compte en fin de compte de
leurs besoins et de leurs plans de
développement
ces écoles ne bénéficions d'aucune aide
de l'état elles doivent s'autofinancer
pour payer leurs locaux les salaires des
enseignants le matériel ce qui implique
des frais de scolarité très élevé pour
les familles un facteur on a changé le
projet en fait par rapport à ça pour
pouvoir justement frère ça nos enfants
puissent confier un deuxième qui suit
juste moitié va rentrer en septembre
donc c'est un vrai choix de venir et des
écoles qui convienne à certains enfants
mais pas à d'autres
et aujourd'hui les parents n'hésitent
plus à faire des allers retours entre le
public et le privé